hey guys I know there's a trying time
for all of us and we're all trying to
just get through this as quickly and
easily as we can but there's a group of
people that haven't been representative
that I really have enough tough time and
I I know there's a lot of very wealthy
people out there you know going without
their amenities and this is for them
imagine there's no Kido
you have to eat mostly carbs I almost
went to my vacation home but they closed
the borders to Martha's Vineyard I'm a
prisoner in my mansion it's smaller than
you think I ran out of kombucha the maid
won't come how'd you clean a sink the
pawl without at my house I freaked out
but it came right back Oh some may say
that I'm wealthy but I've only got three
cars and I can't drive them anyway
because they lock the gate at my gated
community
I heard gluten gives you her owner and
this dog won't walking so the nanny's
with her own family all she cares about
is herself
imagine all the people
[Music]
shirring around the world by
then there be less for me that's
complete so screw all you haters and my
garage is full of toilet paper
[Music]